那我们今天讲座就是我们邀请到马克洋就是参加我们的来当来宾参加我们的讲座
那就是主题是用数学预判理性预判人性的交易心理与行为经济学
那其实我那我本身我的名字叫张冬生我之前的主持人
那我其实在群艺就是负责专门邀请讲师来跟我讲座
然后你们一开始有交我们来然后我们会给你们那个回馈表单
那你们可以跟我们回馈一下就是今天讲座
然后也可以想说你们想要邀请哪些讲师
其实之后我们都可以再办
然后然后给我们好好的回馈
然后我们之后也可以再邀请马克洋再来一次这样
那其实我之前就是会讀马克洋是因为他之前有开实况
然后就是我之前有看到
然后就觉得还蛮好看
然后对然后就是前几个月就发现
他那个开始的时候开始讲股票
就是然后就是觉得
然后跟我本业就是有关
然后所以想说可以邀请他来讲
那个我们的这个讲座
那我们就废话就是说什么
就直接邀请马克洋直接上台了
好给大家一个掌声
赞
好谢谢众生
我是马克洋
然后现场应该很多人是跟我第一次见面嘛
然后我待会还是会简单的自我介绍一下
然后我今天讲的内容主要都是跟交易心理比较有关的
然后我自己是很擅长数学还有行为经济学
就是我对心理学这方面比较有研究
然后我希望我今天的演讲应该会跟
就是你们平常在试验上听到的投资分享都很不一样
这样
然后我还是稍微自我介绍一下
就是可能还有一些人
没有很认识我
就是我的本名叫杨正
然后以前那个大学一开始的时候
大家刚创FB的时候都用英文名字
就叫马克洋
所以我就叫马克洋
然后我以前是洋民医学系的医生
然后在这个年轻高中的时候
在剑中有拿过一次科学奥运的金牌
就是当时地上最会考试的人
这样就是考试是我最强的一个游戏
然后后来我没当医生之后
我就去当卢师的实况主
然后还有当游戏的职业选手
基本上那也算是一个数学游戏吧
就是我对数学啊赛局啊
这是比较擅长的
然后今天这些也是我比较能跟大家分享的部分
然后我从小就一直很专精数学
然后到大学之后
我有当过几年舞台剧演员
然后后来就是有跟一个心理师交往过
所以那段时间我就蛮认真研究心理学
那就我对心理学也很有研究
然后后来我有在做补习班老师
做阳正数理教育
主要是教数学数理的
然后在去年
这个可能大家比较知道
就是航运五分盘的时候
我制定了一个利用特殊规则的一些巧门
来达到这个非常好效果的特殊策略
然后这个交易它本身就是一个数学游戏嘛
然后我基本上我玩游戏都真的蛮强的
就是其实每个游戏你玩的方式
然后进步的方式都是很类似的
然后就我以前有玩过什么围棋啊
然后科学竞赛啊
然后星海争霸四季啊
就是很多
然后就是如实
我有一段时间是常常出国比赛
然后一拳超人是一个除职游戏
我也除到伺服器第一
就那时候觉得反正没差嘛
就其实我真的是觉得
现实生活的钱跟游戏币
本来就是可以等价互换的
就是
其实钱也就是游戏币嘛
就是人生这个游戏的游戏币
你总是还是要把它换成一些其他的东西
快乐什么的
才会变得有价值
然后最后就是
不知道大家有没有看过
有人有看过考试读心术的影片吗
年轻人好像比较有看过
就是
我有一套比较特别的考试方法
也是考试这个游戏我认为比较正确的游玩方式
好猛喔
这个还有
有人可以抄笔记
这个
这个不用抄笔记好不好
就是
就是你可能觉得
你要给小孩下围棋
下面那个游戏
也可以去下载给小孩玩一下
这个都没问题
不过就是演讲结束之后
我会把那个PTT可以免费给大家
就是
就是不用抄
不用抄任何笔记
也不用什么拿手机起来
然后一张一张拍
就有这个
我PTT做的有点多张
所以就是
反正最后我都可以免费给大家
没有关系
就是大家可以不用抄笔记
好
然后我
稍微介绍一下我的马克洋系统
就是它是一套知识体系
就我认为啊
就是
基本上
你学会了
这套体系里面大部分事情的话
你就可以很有效的达到
支配钱跟支配人这两个目的
那我觉得达到支配钱跟支配人
你能够做到的事情就是
大部分的事情
你想要做大部分都可以做得到
然后
我觉得
就是基本上学校需要的必修
就只有数学跟心理学
就其他的都可以列为选修
就是要不要上都没关系
但是这些是对你的人生会
最有影响的
然后
具体有哪些我后面再
稍微讲好
不然我现在讲大概也不太知道
但是
反正就是前面数学这一类就是
让你可以
玩游戏或者是做任何
有规则的事情的时候都很强
然后就是不管是股市啊
考试啊任何东西
然后心理学那个就是
你比较知道
每一个人他是什么样的个性
然后
人是怎么思考的
你要怎么样给别人刺激
让别人可以做出
你希望他做的决定
然后还有
你比较能知道别人在想什么
然后
那因为要学的东西蛮多的
所以我旁边有一个
辅助这个体系的就是
高效学习跟超强记忆的方式
就其实这些也跟心理学有点关系
高效哥比较有关系
就是科学家
发现了一套
怎样学习比较好的方法
然后
在数学跟心理学的
这个结合
就是我今天主要的主题
行为经济学
就是怎么用数学计算人性
很多人都会以为
人性怎么能计算呢
那个都算不出来的
就是你怎么知道别人会做什么事
就是如果是
少少的一个人两个人他会做什么事的话
那就比较适合用
人格的分类和读心术来
分析判断他比较有可能做什么
但如果是一大群人的话
就比较适合用行为经济学来
判断这个人会做什么
这一群人会做什么事情
然后人会有什么样的偏误
那这是行为经济学主要研究的东西
然后当然
因为一大群人就是股市嘛
所以我们比较适合
用行为经济学来分析这些事情
然后这个体系就可以让你达到
基本上可以支配钱和支配人的效果
然后
我这边说的支配
就是大家常常对这个词有一个误解就是
你是不是拿一个棍子
然后强迫别人听你的话做某件事情
就是不是
支配钱跟支配人是
让别人自然而然的做出
你想要他做的决定
然后还有让钱自然而然的就留向你这边
就不是说你拿个棍子
叫别人把钱交出来
然后
今天的主题是行为经济学
就是用数学描述人性
我们先用数学可以描述这些事情
然后知道大家会犯什么样的错误
然后知道我们人是怎么样接收讯息的
然后就用数学描述人会犯的错误
和怎么解决他
然后
第一个是为什么要凭数学交易
而不能凭人性的直觉交易
今天我会讲非常多个人性很常见的偏误
偏误就是
BIOS
就是偏见错误
就是人
人都会犯一样的错误
而且犯的错误的方向都类似
那
大概主要的原因就是这样
主要就是因为人是不理性的
那有时候有些人
就是会收到一些讯息问我说
老师能不能分享高胜率的策略
然后有一次
这个有一个人他觅我
然后他说他是学校国中的地理老师
这是真实故事就是
他说
那个马克兰可不可以跟我分享你的高胜率策略
他说他想到一个高胜率策略
他
他自己虽然没有下过单交易
可是他是教地理的
他在看那个课本的那个等高线图的时候
他有一个领悟
就是说那个台子旗
他现在他说这个方法最厉害的地方是
你可以在任何一个时间点
在任何一个地方打多单或空单
你就随便就
就塞多单或空单进去
然后呢
如果同方向走50点你就挺立
如果反方向走50点呢
你就加倍加码再摊平
再往下走50点就再摊平一次
你就一直摊
到最后只要他往上走一次50点
你就赚50点了
这是他想出来的方法
然后他说
这个
大概他抓最多加码4次
然后他看了最近10天的那个走势图
都会赢50点
他说你看
我这个方法太厉害了
这个
然后他就说马克养
你看我把我这个
看地图的等高线图看到的独门秘诀跟你讲
你也把你的秘诀跟我讲好不好
大家觉得他说的这个策略是很烂的策略的举手
其实很少人知道这是很烂的策略嘛
好谢谢大家
你稍微跟大家讲一下为什么这是一个很烂的策略
我觉得加码那是钱要够多
就是不然永远贪不下去啊
那如果有1亿的话这是一个好的策略嘛
因为2的n次方便1亿很快就没有了
对对对就是他意思是说要有无限钱才能执行这个策略
1亿也太少嘛对不对
这些同学讲的很好
就是
就是这是一个超级烂的方法
就是你去
这是一个很常见人会不小心影响出来的方法
而且大家都会独立想出这个方法
就是你去赌场的时候
你就压大小你就压1块钱
输了就在压2块
又输了就输3块嘛
你就在压4块
赢了是不是又凹回1块又赢1块
输了变输7块你就在压8块
这个是一个
不知道为什么大家都会自然而然想出来的方法
好其实再过几张投影片
你们就会知道为什么大家会想出这样的方法
然后这是一个非常烂的策略
就是基本上
他的结局就一定是破产
就是只要他会连续赢很多次1块钱
然后最后再一次的时候
输非常多钱直接破产
那这是一个超高胜率的策略
但是他的结局最后一定是破产
那这就是人性会自然发展出来的策略
因为人会太过度的在意
那个胜率是不是很高
然后他说那你也给我
跟我讲那个秘诀好不好
我跟他说那个
我给你一个价值几十万的建议
就是你的方法就是垃圾
不要用这个方法下蛋
然后他就很生气
他就把我封锁了
然后这个就是
胜率99.9%的策略就是
你把那个加码4次
改成加码10次嘛
对不对
然后2的10次就是1024嘛
那这样的话你就只有1024分之1的机会
会输钱
但是只要遇到一次你就破产了
所以这是一个非常烂的策略
就是我们应该要找的策略是正确的策略
而不是高胜率的策略
就是只要停损超级宽
胜率就可以拉很高
但是长期会输钱
-EV就是他的期望值是负的
就是
expected value是负的
然后这是很直觉也很烂的策略
那
所以我们要找出的是正确的策略
然后正确的策略有哪些需要达到的
就是第一个是要有的期望值嘛
但其实在市面上有很多的老师他们都会
就是
就是他们可能可以常常贴出赚钱的对账单
但那其实是很没有意义的
就是
他常常可以赚钱不代表他长期是赚钱的
因为他可能每次都赢10万
但是有一天输1000万
这就是每次都赢1块
最后输1000块嘛
所以其实我们要学会
怎么样判断
这个一个策略是不是正确的
那第一个就是至少他的期望值要是正的
期望值负的策略
就完全没有参考价值
因为他长期就是输钱的
然后
另一个是下注的尺度
那下注的尺度就是
可以用凯利公式来大概
抓一下你自己下注的尺度
那他会跟
这个
你每一次赢会赚几倍
还有
获胜的胜率有关
那最后你会知道你每一次下注
应该下注的比例是多少
那这个是比较适合在
你的资金至少有几十万以上的时候
你会下不止一口的时候
你就
应该稍微用这件事情来衡量
那
其实我们通常不一定能够知道
胜率跟赔率的具体数字
所以这是抓一个大概的想法
你大概可以知道说
你不应该下注超过什么样的尺度
然后
胜率越高
汗赔率越高你就会下注越大
那基本上
这个
很多的大师就是真的
很厉害的公认的国外大师
大部分的意见都是
不要单压持仓超过
20%
就是单一个股不要
持有超过25%的部位
然后
你可以从10%的部位开始
再慢慢加到25%
但是不要超过
然后
还有一单的停损不要超过总资金的2%
那当然这个都是
你可以做复述口的时候才能做的
那他的想法就是
鸡蛋不要放在同一个篮子
而且定出一个非常具体的数字
告诉大家
一单的停损不要超过总资金的2%
那你就更能够知道
你应该一次要下注几口
然后你的停损应该要拉多宽
那这个是很重要的
就是
反正不用炒
就是因为我最后
我会把那个PowerPoint都给你们
因为我看大家还是
一直炒
就是你会打到一整份投影片
好
然后
这个
鸡蛋不要放在同一个篮子里
但如果你只有一颗鸡蛋的话
那你就好好保护它
因为只有一颗鸡蛋
它一定在同一个篮子里
对不对
就是
我说的是
有复述口的情况
你如果总共只能打一口小胎
那就
那就先去好好赚钱
我后面也会讲
就是我建议
你资金如果在
总资金在30万以下的话
你应该优先
去学习提高你的收入
而不是投资
因为
投资你是用指数成长嘛
但是你一开始的数字实在太小了
你用线性增加
就是一个小时赚个300、500
可能都赚得比你
用乘法来乘还快
好
然后我这边是要讲的是
什么是正确的策略
就是一个正确的策略
它其实不需要胜率很高
它胜率低也没关系
然后就是你应该考虑
除了胜率之外还有赔率
然后这会影响你的期望值是不是正的
然后再来就是
风险程度
第一个是最大回档
这个是一定要知道的
就是
如果你的最大回档
会让你破产一次的话
那后面就算它在涨也都没用了
因为你破产一次你就出局
就归零了
然后最后是
这个策略它可能
就是数据都很好
然后最大回档也很好
但是呢
他只
像那个D老师嘛
他看了10天的线图
他就说这是一个超棒的数据
那这个它的power就是统计上面
它这个解析的力量就很小
因为它的数据实在是太少了
那
这个
就是
另外一个
需要注意的就是
你在
其实你在市面上你买到了很多
有可能它的这些数据都很好
但它还是一个很好的科学
的原因就是
overfitting的关系
就是
因为其实现在的电脑
你能够
强迫它去跑
例如说跑10个策略
然后这10个策略呢
你都让它看
1分K 2分K 3分K 4分K
看到60分K
1分K到60分K
跑60次
然后
它还可以再帮你去截取周期
就是从几号到几号
你的数据看起来会最好看
所以如果你看到有人
或者是你买到一个策略
然后它是说什么
什么
从2015年到2018年回测
然后看22分K的某一个技术指标
你看
这个左下到右上赚超多钱
然后
这个每一个数字都超级漂亮
你还是要知道
这个应该就是一个垃圾策略
就是如果它没有办法很好的解释
为什么它是回测2015到2018
而不是回测到现在2022呢
一个正常的策略回测
至少要回测到近期嘛
然后尤其是有交易规则的改变之后发生的事情
都应该要回测
那在2020跟2021明显有交易规则的巨大改变
为什么它有规则改变之后的反而不回测
它更应该回测的是交易规则改变之后的数据
然后
就是
为什么它看的是什么
22分K
就是
那为什么它不看20分K呢
就是除非它有一个很好的理由
不然的话基本上它就只是
用电脑按了那个最佳化
然后做了一个overfitting的结论
overfitting
大概的意思就是说
我们的电脑都可以去找出一些规律
然后例如说
我们班上
我给电脑一个名单
就是从
班上这个
1号到
30号的人
然后
他们的名字叫什么
然后他们
这次考试考几分
那就变成1,2,3,4,5
也是一组数据
它就自己抓了一些结论
如果下一个同学的行业比划比前一个多
分数就会上涨
分数下降的话
那性命比划应该就下降
但是有一些例外
姓陈姓张和姓李的不符合这个规则
就它可能会自己去抓一些这些规律
然后它最后就是说
所以我们判断如果有一个新来转学生是31号
我们可以猜出他
期末考一考几分
我们就看他姓名比划
你看是不是很准
就是
就是这个就是一种overfitting
它听起来就很荒谬嘛
但是它却看起来可能可以很准
那这个也是大家需要注意的
就是
所以其实基本上要学会数学和统计学都是非常重要的
就是你比较不会不小心学到一个很烂的策略
然后还以为这是一个好的策略
然后就是卖这种
我刚刚说的类似那样的策略的人其实是很常见
就是他就是按一下最佳话
然后就出现一个策略
好就是大家稍微讲一下什么是正确的策略
好那就是这世界坏了很多
学会判断什么是正确的策略
然后再来就是规则一是
你应该更长的持有正确的仓位
跟更短的持有错误的仓位
这听起来很像废话
不过这个是很重要的
就是因为人性会让我们做出完全相反的事情
就是正在往上获利奔跑的仓位
很容易被我们砍掉
然后在亏钱的仓位
我们会很容易不愿意停损
但是我们应该做的事情应该相反嘛
就是它在多头趋势往上涨
然后你打的是多单
那你就应该报这个单更久
那如果你打的是空单
你就应该赶快砍掉
对吧
这个应该非常的容易理解
好那这个
有一次有一个人他跟我说
这也是真的
就是他说他现在股票
帐户里面的所有股票都是赔钱的状态
我想说哇靠
你这个选股也选的太准了吧
为什么有个人这么准
他说因为赚钱的股票
他都获利了结卖掉了
那赔钱的股票呢
他全部都留下来
他等这些涨回到赚5%的时候
他或者是打平的时候
他再把直接卖掉
那这样的话他所有的股票
就都是打平或者是赚钱
那他自己觉得这是一个好的方法
那有没有人也是
就是股票涨了赚钱会卖掉
然后亏的就会留下来
有吗
好像没有人做这么奇怪的事情
但是其实这个好像还蛮常见的
就是这个也很符合人性
就是这个是完全相反的方向
你应该要做的是
把所有亏钱的股票都卖掉
然后留下赚钱的
这个才是继续持有正确的仓位
然后砍掉错误的仓位
那人性会让不同的人都犯一样的错
那接下来我会讲的这个是
为什么大家会太早停利跟太晚停损
好那我先稍微简单介绍一下
就是经济学里面有一个很基本的观念
叫做编辑效用递减
DMU
Diminishing Marginal Utility
然后 Utility就是
它的本身自翻译是效用
然后我通常会翻译成快乐值
然后这个
教我经济学的老师
他通常都翻译成爽度
反正意思就是说呢
这个东西带给你的快乐程度
就是 Utility
那Utility
那Utility跟金钱
是不是线性的关系的
那因为
因为
都一样是增加100万
对于比较
窮的人来说
这个增加的快乐是非常多
这边是说10万美元
大概是300万
你看
如果你突然中奖
中了一个彩票
中了300万
你赶快打给你的家人
我中了300万彩票
那你妈可能会觉得
这么好
中300万
你们两个都很开心
但是在这边的人
这可能是郭台铭
他的秘书打电话来
他说
郭董
那个今天你的股票
涨了0.1块
你赚了10万美金
哇
那郭董绝对把他臭骂一顿
直接开除
对吧
就是
因为对有钱人来说
10万美金的财富增加
是
增加的快乐是非常少的
欸
有没有人到这边就已经听不懂了
应该没有吧
好
那
这个就是
这个他画的地方只有在
这边是财富
这边是效用
因为我要先确定
大家是能够看得懂图表的
然后
展望理论就是
人对损失会比
获得更加敏感
然后并且可以以此
画出一个价值函数
那这个价值函数是这样
就是
这边还是一样
这边你可以说这边是钱
然后这边是
效用
就是utility
那我们对于损失
损失100块
的不开心
跟得到100块的开心
这个是有一个程度上的差距
可能会差到两倍以上
就是
你如果
今天
得到了100块
之后
或者说
你今天赚了100万之后
又赔了100万回去
你今天的心情
是觉得
觉得今天心情很好的举手
觉得今天心情是
不赚不赔的举手
有一些人
觉得今天心情超不爽的举手
对吧
应该大部分人是超不爽
但是
其实你的钱没有变多也没变少
但是你
增加了100万的快乐
100万元的快乐
然后又赔了100万回去
但你是超不爽
就是这个是
价值函数
就是我们人性
就是对于
获得和损失的感受
是不一样的
然后再来另外一个
值得注意的点
就是
Marginal Utility Deminition
这一个函数在这边
凹口是向下的
在这边凹口是向上的
那这就会导致一件事情
就是呢
如果我现在打了一单进去
打单在这边
然后我定的
停损跟停力是2R好了
就是2R的意思就是说
我的停损是100
我的停力是200
就是R就是我的风险
就是我在付100块的时候
我会把这单砍掉
就是赔100块
然后停力就是说
我到赚200块的时候
我会把这单砍掉
那就是赚200块
那这样的赔率的话
我赢一次可以输两次嘛
所以我胜率只需要有多少就可以了
50%吗
没有不用那么高
33%
对对对33%
好
所以那例如说我打一个单
我打一个2R的单
我停损-100
停力振200
可是我到这个正100的时候
这边我就发现一件事情
就是那个tick在这个附近跳动的时候
大家知道tick是什么吧
就是那个价钱在这个附近跳动的时候
我发现它每一次扣100块
我减损的那个不爽程度
我减少的快乐减少很多
但是我往上跳一点点tick的时候
我增加的快乐好像没有很多
就是例如说100跳到90
跟100跳到110的时候
我发现跳到90我好不爽
跳到110我一直觉得一点点快乐
怎么办
算了啦
不要管什么2R
我100块就砍掉了
就在那边跳来跳去
我很怕它跌啊
然后其实涨我也觉得还好
但我真的很怕它跌
100块就停力就砍掉了
但是在-100的地方呢
它会是完全相反的
就是它往下多亏100块的时候
-100变-110的时候
我只多亏一点点
或者说你看从这边到这边好了
从-1到-200
这边和这边
我只多不爽这样子
但是它往回弹回去的时候
我减少的不爽这么多
所以我其实觉得它往下亏更多
没什么关系
但是亏更少的时候
我觉得我重苦减少蛮多的
所以呢
我有可能做的事情是什么
就是如果我停损在这边
我有可能在这边
我就把它停损掉了
所以
欸不是不是
是我会不停损啦
我讲反了
它在往下走
它我增加的不开心也没有很多嘛
但是往回走的时候
我减少的不开心很多
所以我会不想把这单砍掉
就是我应该在-100的时候停损
但我却没有停损
因为我很希望它往回跳回去
把这一段不开心吃回去嘛
啊就算亏两倍
我也才增加这样一点点不开心啊
我的不开心从这边到这边
我比较希望它扣回去嘛
所以我在-100的时候可能会不停损
然后在-100的时候太快停力
太快停力
欸听得懂吗
听得懂
好欸喔还不错不错
大家都听得懂
好
这个大家都很聪明
看来大家都看得懂
这个数学图表
好这个还不错
然后这个就是展望理论
就是为什么我们会太早停力太晚停顺
就是人性必然导致的结果
然后就是学习行为经济学
就是比较能够让大家知道
我们自然而然就是都会犯什么样的错误
然后我们会知道我们自己
心里现在的这个感觉是错的
我们不应该这样做
我们应该依据数学逻辑来行事
好然后这个就是
但是看起来大家都看得懂嘛
就是你收益增加快乐的放大也不多
损失增加痛苦的放大也很少
所以人性就会导致没有受过的交易者注定会赔钱
因为他们会
做跟规则依完全相反的事情
他们会太早停力而太晚停顺
所以他们持有错误仓位的时间会更长
持有正确仓位的时间更短
这个应该大家都听得懂
好然后
这个就是
我刚刚讲那个
拗口向上跟拗口向下这件事情
就是如果你有高中以上的数学程度的话
你就会知道拗口向上跟拗口向下
它的二次微分的正负是什么样的差异
所以你看到那个图表你很快就可以知道
而不需要就是在那边看
然后这边往前一点它的斜率怎样
往后一点斜率怎样
就是这个过程就可以在你看到图表的瞬间
你光知道这个图形是拗口向上还是拗口向下
就能够做出这样的判断
那所以基本上
数学对于你的一辈子都是有非常重要而深远的帮助
就是
它几乎是学校最重要的科目
就是如果你还在学校的话
可以好好学这一科
我看后面有不到十岁的小妹妹来
稍微跟她讲一下
就是要好好学数学这样
好
然后更高的数学程度呢
让你更快速用更高的观点做出判断
而且是快速的做出判断
马上知道做出判断的方向在哪
好
那这个是人性很容易做的
赚钱的单赶快砍掉
赔钱的单先留下来
最后满手都是绿字的股票
那到底在干嘛
就是跟
那个规则一看起来超像废话
正确的仓位持有更长
错误仓位持有更短
结果大家都做完全相反的事
好
然后另外就是犹豫和害怕输钱
会让你输更多钱
我非常建议就是用触价停损
就是到价停损
如果你设的停损是这个数字
到了就直接停损砍出去
或者是直接用电脑帮你触价单
就停损出去
不然的话很有可能
人性的就是到-100了要停损
等一下再看一下好了
再看一下好了
这个扣一点点回去我减少的
就是我刚刚说的那件事情
好
所以
这个
就是
就是有很多的券商会有这种
到价自动停损的
这个大家可以考虑一下
这样
然后再来就是
用行为经济学征服世界
这个是一个有趣的事情
就是行为经济学
显然它不是只能用在股市
它也可以用在生活中的任何情况
我做计程车的时候
有时候都会跟司机稍微聊天
然后因为这个也是
这个行为经济学的教科书上面
会有的例子
所以我就
会稍微访谈一下计程车司机
我问他说
你平常上班是
是怎么样决定
你今天要跑多长的班
那有一些人
有一些计程车司机
他的方法是
我今天就跑八个小时
固定时间
第二个方法是
我一天就赚2000块
我跑到2000块
我就回去
我如果
就是一直
开来开去
可是没办法
我抓我一天就是要赚2000块
那我就会跑更长的时间
才到2000块
这个是固定金额
但是其实这两个方法
都不太正确
比较正确的方法是什么
是
如果你今天
更快的
赚到了2000块
那你今天就应该要跑更久时间的班
例如说你抓
前面的一段时间
你赚的金额如果是超过某个数值
你今天就继续跑
继续开车
因为今天可能是某个
他不需要知道的原因
而且是很多原因的综合
今天大家比较需要搭计程车
可能是下雨的天气
可能是放假
可能是某个节日
但其实司机不需要知道
就跟股票一样
我们其实不需要知道
因为这个都是混合的原因
但是今天继续跑
每个小时赚的钱会更多
那如果今天
前几个小时生意都很差
那他就应该回家了
因为他后面几个小时
生意应该还是会很差
这个跟我们刚刚的那件事情
是几乎一样的
就是你报正确的仓位
应该要报得更久
报错误的仓位
应该要报得更短
但是非常少的计程车司机
要能够做出这样的上班策略
对吧
就是前两个策略
都是人很容易想到的
我固定上班的时间
或固定赚的金额
但是其实更好的是
我如果今天前面赚更多钱
我就跑更久的班
如果我今天赚前面很少钱
我就跑更短的班
像我上班时间一样
例如说我都抓
我一个礼拜就跑
这个50个小时的班
那你赚到的总共金额
反而会增加
大家应该听得懂吧
这个就是行为经济学
能够让你做到的事情
就是你光是
改变你跑的上班的方式
就可以在一样的时间
赚到更多的钱
好
然后
这个是实际上
有厉害的人是这样做的
但我不是这样做
我做的这个周期比较短
就是呢
他一开始先用某些方式
选10支
当季他觉得最好的股票
然后各投入1/10的仓位
然后每过一个周期
例如说每过一个月
他就重新检视
这些股票里面哪些是赔钱的
只要是绿字赔钱的
就全部卖掉
然后平均分散到赚钱的股票里面
去买那些赚钱的股票
所以股票就会越来越少
就是输钱的那些会被砍掉
然后变成赚钱的股票
这个才是符合规则1
比较正确的做法
但是
其实有很多股市的行手
他们的做法完全相反
他们把赚钱的股票砍掉
然后再拿去摊平
去摊平赔钱的股票
他就更多的持有错误的仓位
那这个是一个好的方法
那当然这个方法
他有一个分支情况
就是
如果你十支股票都在赔钱怎么办
那你当然就是全部砍掉
那现在可能是在崩盘
或者是你一开始选股的方式
很有问题
那就全部都砍掉
那没有任何要买回来的股票
这个也是很合理的
对吧
好这个也是一个中长期波段的策略
然后为什么我们一定要学行为经济学
就是传统经济学跟行为经济学
的这个世界观是完全不一样的
传统经济学认为
人会尽量做出最好的决定
然后就四折五入
那大家应该会做出最好的决定吧
哇这也太荒谬了吧
就是
大家真的会做出最好的决定嘛
大家会最佳化optimize自己的选择嘛
然后
那个传统经济学家就说
就算大家可能不懂数学和经济学
但是用
假设大家都做最好的决定
来模理人类的集体行为
应该也够接近了吧
因为他们的想法是这样
最好的决定在这边
大家会尽量去接近最好的决定
所以有些人会不小心
就是做决定在上面
有些人会做决定在下面一点
平均来说
应该大概就是平均在最好的决定这边吧
但是呢
在最近十几二十年
行为经济学才开始兴盛
行为经济学是一个非常新兴的学科
就是都是
算是很新的概念
就十几二十年才有新概念
就是人会犯的错误
其实大家会一起偏向同一个方向
那这样大家的错误
就不能够近似抵消了
因为大家都高估或大家都低估
那就会全部偏往同一个方向
大家应该听得懂这个意思吧
好
很多人都说什么
市场是对的吗
就是当然不是嘛
但是很多人都说市场是对的
人理性吗
人当然是不理性的嘛
而且这些不理性是我们能够用数学来描述的
那以前的问题就是
人不理性但是也不知道怎么计算
那就算了吧
反正我们就当大家的不理性会抵消
但其实不是这样
就如果
其实在传统经济学还有一个很有趣的悖论
哇这也可以当悖论
悖论就是一个
听起来很荒谬
但你不知道怎么反驳的理论
就是说呢
因为大家都知道
大家都很厉害嘛
大家都会做出最优化的决定
那就没有一个人
会把股票卖给另一个人啊
因为如果大家都知道
待会比较高机率会涨的话
那怎么会有一个人愿意卖给另一个人呢
他们的观点是相反的
那当然
这个在现代就根本不值得称为悖论嘛
因为人就不是理性的
好
然后所以我接下来
会非常多的讲
就是
就是人会犯哪些错误
然后让大家了解
这个人会犯的错误有哪些
那我先讲一下
这个是传统经济学
一个很经典
放在教科书里面
告诉大家人是怎么思考的例子
叫做海盗分金币
那中国的版本就叫三基分金
就说
这个海盗的黑帮船
船长让ABC三个船员分100万的金币
A是最大的
然后在B和C它的阶级比较低
依序阶级是ABC
然后他们可以依序提议分金币的方式
但是A先提议
例如说A说
我比较大
我40万
你们两个30万
然后呢
三个人就投票
如果
只能投好或不好
然后
如果超过一半同意
就是三个人里面有两个人同意
就依照这个提议分钱
好那就40万、30万、30万分
如果没有过半的话
BC都把它否决掉
A说好
BC说
凭什么以拿40
你怎样
我们为什么只有30
那A就被丢到海里去
大家听得懂这个意思吧
然后再换B来提议
然后B如果也被丢到海里
就换C提议
大家听得懂吧
丢到海里就是去喂鲨鱼
就死了
大家听得懂这个故事吧
那
这个故事
你觉得
你觉得A会怎么提
A喔
我是A的话就给BC各50万
他给BC各50万
不然他觉得自己会被丢到海里
一定会被丢
对
对啊
这可能是一个想法
但这个就是有点过度的猜测
因为其实经济学家根本不是这样想
但是你很好
你已经进入了开始预判别人会做什么的领域
实际上的情况不是A会给BC50万喔
传统经济学家认为的结局是
A说
我负责分喔
那我拿100万
你们两个零块
来
同不同意
你们就按嘛
同不同意嘛
C就直接拍桌子
这个
有录影不适合骂账话
你
你三小啊
我就按他
然后他就看B
这样干嘛
干这个人还不会被丢到海里去喔
然后B就想了一下
B就
按圈
然后A就
欸嘿嘿
按一个圈
欸我拿100万
你们两个零块
然后C就很惊讶
C就说
哪尼
B你为什么要同意
然后A就说
A就像那个什么
凱斯日本漫画这样
推一推眼镜就说
C啊
如果我被丢到海里的话
就只剩下
B跟C了
那B就会知道
你不管
不管B给C多少钱
C都可以按X
把B丢进海里
从此以后
船上就只剩下C了
以后每一次所有钱都会分给C
所以B会尽力的
让A不被丢到海里
因为A只要被丢到海里
B就会被丢到海里
也就是说呢
因为B预判了C的行为
然后A预判了C对B的预判
所以A就推一推眼镜说
我预判了你的预判
所以
你们两个都只能拿0块钱
哇
传统经济学家认为是这样的结局
就是
这是日本漫画看太多了是不是
为什么传统经济学家
在课本里面写说
所以
现实世界的人类
我们应该用这样的方式
去模拟大家的行为
这样想的经济学家
怎么还没被丢进海里啊
然后
他们那个会议就是这样
就是一个人
站在上面
然后下面全部都做经济学家
因为是经济学论坛
他就讲讲讲讲讲
然后说
有人听不懂吗
然后下面的每个人都
嗯
很有道理
那肯定不是我听不懂
一定是他讲的很有道理
然后大家就觉得
嗯很有道理
但现实世界肯定不是这样嘛
这个人
光是他说一百万的时候
都还没投票
就是
就直接被丢到海里去了吧
就怎么可能是这样的
那
这边是讲说
就是
传统经济学说
人是理性的这件事情
绝对是非常不合理的
那另外一个
大家
大家知道什么是机会成本吗
诶
知道什么是机会成本的人很少是不是
好好好
这个可能要
这个
有
离学校比较近一点
国中的那个
课本
社会课本好像有叫
机会成本
opportunity cost
的意思是
你因为要做这个决定
而要放弃的
最高价值的另一个决定
就是例如说
我要跟三个男生交往
然后
我选这个男人
那我放弃的第二好的男人
就是我的机会成本
所以我不会选第二好的男人
因为我放弃的最好的男人
机会成本比较高
我们会做出机会成本最低的决定
好
所以传统经济学家认为
你在睡前还有三十分钟可以用
你要决定你这三十分钟要干嘛
你会怎么做呢
你会在纸上画一个表格
决定你睡前三十分钟要干嘛
打个手枪好了
快乐值150
还是看马克上直播
快乐值120
还是写一下明天的作业
快乐值只有100
然后我就列出来
我要放弃的决定是怎样
我发现这两个
要放弃的是150
这个是120
所以我们就会做出一个120的决定
就是你睡前还有三十分钟要干嘛
你还要打个手枪
还要画一个表格在那边做决定
没有人这样子做决定的吧
然后还有更聪明的传统经济学家就说
我想到一个方法
可以把机会成本降到100
我一边看马克上直播
一边打手枪
机会成本是不是就降到100了
所以传统经济学家就认为说
我们在睡前还剩30分钟
我们会先列一个表格
然后最后决定看马克上的直播打手枪
我想说这些传统经济学家到底在干嘛
这个是最合理的选择吗
大家真的是这样做决定的吗
我们做决定的现实世界的情况
脑科学告诉我们
我们做的每一个决定
只跟两件事情有关
第一个是你过去思考的习惯
也就是你脑袋里面
已经建立了这些神经连接
第二个就是
现在你接收到的刺激
那因为这个要展开可能
又要再讲很久
所以我就先不展开
反正就是
人不是这样做决定的
人是用过去思考的习惯
加现在接收到的刺激
这两件事情来做决定
而不是在那边算数学
好
然后这个是另外一个故事
是这样
就是某一个
生薰好了
我们的这个摄影帅哥叫生薰
生薰他很喜欢周杰伦
他想要去看周杰伦的演唱会门票
然后他发现那个门票
他发现那个门票要一万块
太贵了吧
看一个演唱会要一万块
虽然周杰伦真的很帅
但一万买不下手啊
可是呢
他看到那个周杰伦
他那个抽
网路上有抽奖
他可以抽那个FB分享
然后他就抽中了一张
一万块的演唱会门票
哇他好高兴喔
我怎么抽到了一万块的演唱会门票
好开心
他就去听周杰伦的演唱会了
他在就是网路上的某一个售票
或者什么什么黄牛平台
他可以很轻易的用一万块买到这张票
也可以很轻易的用一万块
把它拿到那张票卖出去
但是他在原本他没有很轻易的去买那张一万块的票
他在抽到票之后
也没有把那张一万块的票卖掉
有没有人听到这边觉得
太扯了
怎么可能有人这样做决定
有吗有人这样觉得吗
应该没有人这样觉得吧
这个故事听起来超级合理的对吧
大家都很有可能这样做
但是传统经济学家认为
我们他要
声讯要不要去听演唱会
是他会衡量一万块现金的价值
跟去听演唱会的价值哪一个比较高
然后他判断了一万块现金的价值
比听演唱会的utility更高
所以一万块大于演唱会
他就没有去听演唱会
他抽到了门票之后
这件事情也不会改变
一万块的utility
还是大于演唱会的utility
所以他一定会上网
用一万块把那张演唱会的门票卖掉
他根本不可能去看演唱会
这个就是传统经济学的思考模型
但实际上我们根本就不是这样思考的
对吧
刚那个故事非常非常合理
应该没有人听完之后
就拍座的时候
最好是哪有人这样做决定的
一定没有人
不会有人这样想嘛
那另外一个类似的是
有一个人他对花粉过敏
然后他不愿意花五百块
请别人帮他整理花园
因为他觉得很贵
但是你问他那我给你一千块
你花粉过敏去帮别人整理
别人跟你一样的花园
你愿不愿意他也不愿意
这个也是一样的道理嘛
就是整理花园忍受过敏的代价
怎么可能是低于五百块又高于一千块呢
怎么会有数字低于五百又高于一千
因为这是一样的
我就不深入解释
你们自己回去思考
好吧
所以人类根本不是用机会成本加效用来做选择的
然后令人吃惊的是
富人比穷人更接近用机会成本做决策
因为其实机会成本
他说的是
我把这一千块拿来买这个东西
我就会不能买另一个东西
穷人比较会遇到这样的情况
那在台湾大家比较富裕
其实我们比较不会遇到这样的情况
就是你不太会因为
什么我吃了这顿饭
然后我就没有鞋子穿了
就是大概不会有这样的情况
但是穷人也只是更接近用机会成本做决定
他会在那边考虑很久
我买这个就不能买那个
但他也不会做决定都用机会成本
然后就是政府听这些传统经济学家的建议
来制定政策是不是哪里怪怪的
就是经济学家几乎是在政府的论坛里面
提意见听起来最有道理
也最应该被采纳的人
但他们的建议都很奇怪
就是以为大家都很理性来模拟
然后就是这堂课的
其中一个最重要的take-home message
就是人不是理性的
市场是错的
而且人的不理性方向可以预测
然后这个预测方式的最fundamental
最基础的就是前面的那张value curve
价值函数
就是那个图
展望理论的图
然后因为我做的PTT有点多张
反正就是马克洋知识体系里面的这些东西
就是你应该学会这个学校的数学
然后逻辑统计学
基本上我认为
要懂统计学的人才能知道什么是对的
什么是错的
就是不是因为大家都这样说
所以这件事就是对的
判断对错的方式应该是统计学
用某种方式数字去衡量
而不是大家都这样说
然后赛局理论跟游戏规则
你更能够快速的适应游戏规则
你能够知道
怎么样适应游戏规则的变动
然后在这个规则的变动里面
做出更好的选择
然后物理学更让你知道
这个世界上哪些
就是你做什么事情
就是会发生什么事情
然后
好那边我就暂时不讲
反正就是
就是我
这是一个
把它学起来
你就可以很轻易支配钱跟支配人的
这个知识体系
好
然后我们刚刚说
人会倾向于
太快的停力跟太晚的停损
所以在
这个一个大涨跟大跌的趋势盘
就是一路往上涨的时候
打空单的人
他有可能会一直不停损
然后当冲有保证金减半的机制
大家知道吗
就是当冲的话
你如果打旗货当冲
你可以保证金减半
但是在尾盘的时候
你会被强制平仓
那在趋势盘的过程当中
这些不停损的当冲客
是没有机会停损的
因为他们就是不停损
他们就在等回档停损
但就没有回档
所以他们就会在尾盘的时候
被一起强制平仓
系统平仓
那你知道这些人会不停损
空单会在尾盘全部回补
那你会怎么说
是不是就是在他们被强制停损之前
打一个多单
去收他们的手续费
你打了进去之后
他们被强制停损
你的单是不是就上去
然后你就把它除掉
这个就是行为经济学能够做到的事情
或者也不一定行为经济学
就是你已经知道别人人性上
会有一群人犯这样的错误
你就叫他们支付你价值
所以大涨大跌盘
台子旗常常会收在当日最高最低点
但是当然更好的是
你应该去考虑一些圈之谷的试错情况
来更加的知道
但是这个就是另一件事情
反正就是我现在要讲的是
当然就是也还要考虑其他情况
不过这个是一个很可以考虑的情况
而且可以发展成一个完整的策略
就是你知道别人会做什么
你就可以用策略让别人来支付你
你知道他别人
一堆人接下来会做这件事
你就找他一步做这件事
然后让他们帮你推你单子的方向
这个在魔术里面叫one ahead principle
就是魔术读星术都很常用这个方法
就是你永远领先你的对手一步
或是像麒麟王一样
你算三步我就算四步
你算十步你就算十一步
就是我领先你一步的一步这样
当然虽然围棋其实不是这样
但是实际上跟心理有关的东西
常常会使用到one ahead principle
就是你要永远领先你的对手一步
你就会有一个很大的优势
你要
那你要怎么知道对手
接下来会做什么
你要怎么达到这个独心术呢
就是你要
能够换位思考
站在别人的角度思考
还有你要博学多文
那还有一些其他的例子
就是很多人他会看五日线向上向下
但是五日线均线就是
这五天的收盘价
或者是这个五个k棒的收k价
除以五
那下一个位置
就是第二项到第六项
加起来除以五
所以第一项到第五项的平均
小于第二项到第六项的平均
是不是
其实这个A2到A5
全部都可以删掉
然后乘以五
所以其实只要A6大于A1
5NA的均线
例如说5分k就会向上
这个知道
听得懂了 举手
好 很好 大家都很聪明
所以其实我们几乎可以在今天收盘之前
就知道今天五日线会不会向上
另外就是
什么情况他会跌到五日线之下
或是他会涨到五日线之上
其实也是能够事先知道的
今天还没收盘就知道了
那是不是有很多人
他的交易策略是看五日线跟十日线
向上向下
会收到线上还是线下
而他们就会在收盘的时候买或卖
那你知道他们会这样做的话
是不是也能够发展出策略
让这些人一起支付你
然后另外还有一些我突然想到
就是定期定额扣款
你们可以去研究那些定期定额扣款
买股的
他们是在几号的什么时间
会去买股
那你就可以让他们去帮你推一把
那这些人也必须支付你
然后
为什么9.15、9.45常有大波动
这个大家知道吗
因为是在8.45的时候期货开盘嘛
这个是30分跟60分之后
那30跟60
都是1、2、3、5、10、15、30的公倍数
也就是不管你是看1分k、2分k、3分k、5分k、10分k、15分k的人
都会在这个时候做一个新的判断
那所以很有可能他们
有可能都做了相同方向的判断
或者是有些人做那个方向的判断
就会让这个时间出现很大的波动
因为会有很多人同时在这个时候下单
所以其中一个就是
如果你比较保守
你就应该避免在9.15到
和9.45的前1、2分钟下单
那当然
另一个方法就是
我去跟这些人拼
我在这个时间的前1分钟下单
但你一定要清楚你在9.14分下单
你会遭遇什么样的对手
而且对手会做什么事
这个也是我们需要知道的
然后另外一个
我有突然想到也是one ahead
就是巨大资金
他们会需要把进月合约
换仓成远月合约
那他们的过程
就必须要在结算的前几天
去回补他们的空单
然后去打下一个月的空单
他们的期货是用来避险的
所以基本上都是空单
那你就可以去收取他们这些
比如说反一
就是他们换仓的手续费
就是远近月的价差
会因为他们的换仓而有改变
我不知道大家听不听得懂
反正就是也是one ahead
你观察它是在什么时候换仓的
你就在它换仓的前一两天
去打远近月价差的单
近月你就打多单
远月打空单
然后远近月价差
移动扩大的时候你就平常
好 你们自己再回去看
我也没有把它写在PET
好 没关系
反正就是这样
然后读心术建立在强大的
同理心家博学多文商
就是
所以很多人会以为说
马克兰是不是跟你学了心理学之后
就好像那个电影里面
被那个吹风机丢到浴缸里面电到
然后你就听得到别人的声音
然后就直接知道别人在干嘛
就不是 那个是贝卡斯的做法
就是
我认为最接近读心术的是福尔摩斯
我们做的是博学多文加上换位思考
知道别人在想什么
我试着
因为我很了解各种思考的方式
我觉得这个人的个性
会什么样思考
所以我去猜
他会怎么做
这个是对一个人的读心术
那对一群人的话就是
我知道有很大一群人
他们会做什么样的决定
所以
我就去one ahead
所以我在去年也花了蛮多钱去买别人的那种投顾资讯
那我不是要跟他们的单
是我要试着one ahead他们
就是
但我的资金没有到他们往上
我把他们靠下去
因为其实也不需要
就人家全部冲过来
然后你不一定要
被他踩过去
你就跑在他前面
让他们去推你
这个也是一个方法
好
然后
现在好像时间没有很够
读心术的故事
因为跟交易本身没有关系
我先跳过
如果有时间我再讲
这是一个有趣的故事
然后最后通牒赛局
last call
就是
如果
这也是一个很有名的实验
就是
A跟B两个人
一起分10美金
或者是我们就说100台币的钱
好了
然后A可以提议怎么分
B来决定要还是不要
例如说
A说我拿51块
你拿49块
因为我出主意嘛
我多拿一点
B说你干嘛
你不要
那B只要按X
两个人就都是0元
B如果同意
A就是51
B就是49元
那这个在传统经济学的想法里面
A会提议我拿99块
你拿1块
你爱要不要
随便你
你按X你就是0块
你按圈你就是1块
要不要
那传统经济学就认为
大家当然都会按钮
对吧
你按X就0块
按圈就1块
那这怎么比都是按圈嘛
别人给你
例如说
别人给你100块
给你10块
他拿90块
会按圈的举手
对吧
没有人会按圈嘛
当我乞丐是不是
就是不会按圈嘛
那在
这个
就算是在
非洲
做了这个钱等于他们
两个月收入的版本里面
在提议的金额低于20%以下的时候
也会被逼否决
也就是说
我们做决定的方式
就不是那个理性的方式
我们会非常的在乎
这一个决定让我爽不爽
因为其实钱的本质
最后是要换成爽度的
那如果这个决定本身
就让我非常不爽
虽然他会赚钱
我还是很不爽
那我们就还是不会做这个决定
大家能够理解这个意思吗
钱最后是要换成快乐的
如果这个决定让我不快乐
人就会不做这个决定
但我们在交易里面
就不是这样嘛
我们应该是要想办法
赢到最多的钱
而不是想办法
打出最爽的单
对吧
所以人们对于觉得损失的感受
会高于实际的得失
就是我们前面的展望理论
我们会觉得损失会超级不爽
人会过度在意这样不爽
那这个是其中一个就是我们在做隔日冲的时候
如果你做的是连续冲的隔日冲
那你通常我们要做的是强势股的隔日冲
对吧
所以如果今天昨天买了今天开盘开高
我卖了赚了2000块
然后尾盘的时候又往上涨了10块
但是符合我们的进场条件
我觉得明天高机率会开高
要不要买回来
要吧
要买回来吧
因为明天会开高
明天开盘再出掉又赚2000块
那这样不是就20002000就赚4000
那还会有当充的手续费折让
就是交易税减半
又再还你几百块
那尾盘是不是要买回来
可是就有学员说
他今天没有买回来
因为他知道开盘的时候他卖了
如果尾盘的时候买回来
就会APP上面就会显示
当充输1万块
他觉得不行
我如果卖掉我就当充输1万块
那个APP就显示当充输1万块
昨天的那个仓位
会变成赢1万2
但是他不管
反正他就不想要当充输1万块
他尾盘就是不想买回来
因为这样就不爽嘛
那这个就是一个错的想法
当然这是他没想清楚
因为其实在前一天买的那一个单
会赚1万2
虽然中间这一仓是4付1万
这个就是不愿意买回的正确仓位
这个就是人过度的在意
这样感觉心情爽不爽
我就问这个
你到底是想要赢钱
还是想要尽量不要不爽
就是我们来市场是要把这个游戏玩好
尽量赢钱嘛
对吧
好然后就是依照数学逻辑交易
不要跟着盘感交易
就是很多人都
就是很多人你问他说
为什么这边打多单
为什么打空单
很多人都回答说
这是一个盘感啦
感觉啦
你做久了就知道了
这种通常有两种情况
大部分的情况是
他根本搞不清楚自己在做什么
反正他就靠赛嘛
他赚到了他就说
你看就是感觉
赔钱他就说
嗯今天状况不好
大概就是这样嘛
另外一种情况是
他是一个厉害的人
但是他个性比较激发一点
他就不想跟你讲
所以他就说盘感
但其实他有一套方法
他不是很想教你
这个也是有可能的
那我讲完这个之后
中场休息
就是忘记出的昨天单的故事
就是也是一个真实故事
数字我是稍微有调整
如果有一个人
他在他的账户里面
放了100万保证金
他昨天打了两口小台的空单
17600空
然后他做3R
20点停损
60点停力减碼
那其实有第一停力
第二停力
但我们就把故事讲简单一点
他就是在17540会停力好了
然后呢
在第二天的时候
今天
他要打两口小台空单的时候
他突然看到
未平常怎么有两口空单
昨天的空单没有出掉
他就问我说怎么办
现在他要打空单
发现昨天有两口空单
还没出掉
这听起来很蠢
但是其实在交易里面
我们有时候就是会发生这样的事情
有没有人有发生过
就是前面的单以为出掉
但没出掉
对吗
其实很多人有发生过
就有时候就是会发生这样的事情
好
这也是真的事情
就真的发生这样的事情
他现在要打两口空单
结果昨天有两口空单
好
现在有几个选择
第一个是
现在已经17700了
17620要损
那我们纪律操作
把昨天的单损掉
因为620就要损
现在呢
要打空单
我们把那两口17600的空单
平仓掉
再打17700的空单
有没有人觉得这样不错
应该没有吧
应该只有券商会举手吧
就是
那你就莫名其妙缴了两次手续费
然后得到了完全一样的两口空单
但是当时他就是想要这样做
他说
然后另外一个想法就是
再打两口空单
然后或者是
就是
好我就直接讲
正确的方式就是
你就假装那两口空单
今天打的就好了嘛
对不对
那你就
虽然是17600的空单
但你就17720停损
17640停立嘛
你17640停立的时候
虽然账面上是输40点
但是
你就不要管账面嘛
反正
你就把昨天的空单
当成今天的空单来打就好啦
大家应该听得懂嘛
这应该是最合理的做法吧
他停立的时候
会亏40点
也就是他会在-4000块的时候停立
但也没关系嘛
因为主要是他昨天就输了1万了
那他就停损停立
他应该是在今天的这个位置
好
这个就是沉默成本
就是你持有的那个东西
本质上是同一个东西
这样就可以了
至于他
就是
他当初是用多少价钱买到的
其实
没那么重要
那这个故事就是
沉默成本的故事就是
网球肘的病人
我以前有一个病人
在骨科的时候
他是
这个网球肘
就是Lateral Epicondylitis
就是他
反正就是一种肌腱炎
那跟打网球的人
会比较容易得到
然后
他就说
可是没办法
他最近还是要去打网球
因为
他买了3万块的教练课
如果接下来
三个月都不去打
那3万块是不会退他的
那我就说
不行
那你这样子打网球
手会很痛
你这样子网球走
不会好
他说不行我付3万块
我就问他说
那如果这堂课是免费的
你还会去打吗
他就说当然不会啊
免费的我就不用去打
我就是因为付了3万块才去打
有没有人听到这边觉得
这个故事很不合理
或是他思考的方式很不合理
应该没有嘛
但是应该现在大家都知道
他没有忽略沉默成本
他应该很良的是
他每次去打网球造成的不舒服
有没有超过他去打网球的价值
跟他以前付了多少钱
是无关因素
这个大家都听得懂吧
沉默成本是大家非常常犯的一个错
好就是也常有人问我说
医学系读7年不是很久吗
为什么你就不当医生了
就是那是沉默成本嘛
我现在不当医生可以赚更多钱
那我到底干嘛去当医生
是因为我那时候读了几百几千本的书
我一定要给他当报
应该不是这样子嘛
对不对
好就是说不定以后就选个台北市长
也是有可能嘛
然后
好忽略沉默成本
抛开不舍
做出当下最正确的决定
这个真的很重要
就是
就是没办法忽略沉默成本
没有办法隔开不舍
是非常常见的人性错误
然后我们学这些东西的原因就是
你在做出了这个感觉的瞬间
你会突然想到
你能听马克兰讲座
好像说有一个沉默成本
我好像忘了忽略沉默成本了
我就能够知道要怎么做出正确的决定
好然后这个
好下一个主题我们下半场来讲
我们请众生帮大家介绍一下
什么是期货
然后就是期货有一些好处
反正请众生介绍一下
我们现在先休息10分钟
好先休息10分钟是不是
我们30分钟回来
好休息10分钟
好然后
刚刚众生讲我稍微
补充一下就是
如果你是
平常直接挂单的话
你可能只能挂
停损或停利的其中一边
但是有一些券商的功能是
可以挂二折一的就是
例如说你往往方方向20点
跟往同方向60点的时候
他都会再触到那个价钱的时候
在那时候才帮你送出那个单
而不是先挂在那边
那当然会有排队
比较落后的一点点的问题
但是在打台子期的时候
其实还好
然后就是那个二折一
跟平常挂单
就会有不一样的效果
然后
好
另一个忘记要讲什么
好然后继续讲那个
我想起来要讲什么
他刚刚说
电脑跟手机上都可以使用
但我
我非常建议
大家要在电脑上
操作下单
不要用手机下单
就虽然
市面上也有一些人说什么
就是你就用手机下单
就可以怎样怎样赚钱
但是
你们自己观察一下
你看手机的报价
跟电脑的报价
电脑的报价
会比手机的报价快一点点
就是因为一个是有线网路
一个是无线网路
然后
就是
你就想象嘛
如果
你可以
比别人提早知道
接下来的价格波动
然后
你
就是
或是你比别人晚一点点才知道价格波动
然后你才去下单
那你一定
会有非常巨大的劣势
对吧
我们都只是想要
one ahead
然后在那边研究半天
结果
你的网路
害你直接比别人慢
所以我强烈建议就是
用电脑下单
如果是当充
就不要用手机下单
当然
如果你的策略周期比较长
就比较没差
就是
如果差零点几秒
会有差的话
那就应该用电脑下单
就不要什么什么手机当充
然后
讲独徒心理
就是
这也是
一个常见的人性错误
就是
我们赢了很多钱之后
有些人
例如说他是
抓十万的筹码进去
然后他
会把十万的筹码放在左边的口袋
然后又赢了两万
放在右边的口袋
那这两万他就会去随便下注
反正这个两万是
赌场的钱
就是那不是他的钱
对吧
反正你输了就算了嘛
但是其实
就是这个十万跟这个两万
是同样的东西
你都应该用一样的程度去
珍视他们
然后
就是
有一个人
他
他如果
这个礼拜
当充赚钱
他就会把
当充赚钱的部分
拿去买
选择权热投
就是最后一天结算
他就随便
cote put
随便买一个价外
然后十块钱以下的
然后就看当天结算
会不会翻二十倍
因为他有一次翻二十倍
他觉得好爽
我买这个不到十块的东西
最后结算翻二十倍
那我五万就翻到一百万
好舒服
之后他就
每一次
结算的时候
如果他赢钱
他就会把赢钱的一部分
拿去翻二十倍
但是大部分情况会归零
如果你有买过选择权的话
那如果他输钱的时候
他会怎么做呢
他会想说
那翻二十倍的话
要下注多少才能凹回来
我也去买热投
也就是说
不管他赢钱或输钱
他都会去买热投
一个是他想要靠赢的钱
赢更多
一个是他想要
就是去赌运器凹回来
但是买了OP2
就是一个他没有策略
然后-EV
不知道自己在干嘛的行为
但是
不管赢钱或输钱
他都去这样做
我发现那个赢写错了
待会我改一下
赢钱或输钱的情绪
都有可能会让人
过度冲动或过度保守
那也有可能有的人是
就是他赢钱他很怕输回去
他就太早听力
这个也有可能是过度保守
所以就是在on-tilt的时候
绝对不要下单
那在打Poker的时候
就叫做on-er
就是外国人叫on-tilt
就是你的操作跟平衡倾斜
不理智的时候
那就是
其实很多人在已经on-er的时候
他是没有办法控制自己的
所以你要很清楚你在on-er之前
你就要停止下单
或者是你快要on了
你要自己知道
那我给出的其中一个建议是
一天连续输两笔单
今天就再也不要下单了
因为你输到第三笔的时候
很多人就会on了
就是
我不行我一定要凹回来
输两笔好不爽
我一定要再把它尻回来
那我说的是连续输两笔
如果你赢输赢输
那下一笔单
也还是可以再下
虽然已经累积输两笔
但是可能你会没那么昂
然后另外一个原因是
如果你连续输两笔单的话
表示你今天对于盘式的分析
可能是错的
那你就不要再用
你今天对于盘式的看法去下单
可能今天有发生了某一些事情
你不知道是什么
但是它跟你的模型
你的数学model
是不符合的
那可能你没有考虑到
如果往上跳空300点
或往下跳空500点
开盘的情况
会跟你的模拟完全相反
模拟完全相反
然后我突然想到
这个没写进去
就是在看K线的时候
跳空的时候
我们常常会有一个错误
就是它是看那个均线
是看前几根K棒的平均
那你在跳空的时候
如果你突然往上跳空
就是例如说
昨天收在这边
是这样子下来
然后突然跳到这边
然后这边再一路跌下来的过程
它的均线看起来是往上的
就是它均线的方向
跟当天实际的走势会不一样
因为它把昨天很低的那些数据
平均进去
这个是一个技术指标的缺陷
就是大家应该要知道的
就是如果跳空的话
你应该
不应该要把昨天的那几根
很远的地方的K棒
平均进去
我突然想到
提醒大家一下
就是
这有可能就是
你
今天开盘连续输量单的原因
因为你以前没遇过
跳空跳那么远的情况
然后你就一直
你的
model里面有一个系统性的错误
你没有抓出来
好
反正就是
一天连续输量比达
你今天就应该停止下单
然后再来就是
什么是套利
就是
两个商品本质上是同一个商品
但是在不同的时间
或者是不同的空间
或者是不同的平台上
它的价格不一样
然后你就
比较贵的那个打空单
比较便宜的那个打多单
那这样你就会
赚到中间的价差
然后再扣掉交易成本
这个应该大家都知道吧
但是因为现在
现代的时代
就不太会有这样的情况
因为很多城市
会及时监控平衡掉这些价差
大台跟小台
本质上是同一个商品
四口小台就是一口大台
所以大台跟小台
就是不会有
同时都有挂单可以成交
但是差的点数在三点的情况
因为你就可以
就是去直接套利
因为它的交易成本就不到三点
大家应该听得懂吧
那当然
如果是大崩盘的时候
根本没有挂单
那有可能
看起来超过三点
但是因为
你没有办法那样成交嘛
好
反正就是
会及时监控平衡这些价差
所以
基本上在台值期
有大涨或大跌的时候
你可以看到
各个价位
十几个价位的选择权商品
也都会马上的
喷一根出去
因为这些都是电脑在交易
就是他们的速度很快
他们不会让这些价差出现
十几个选择权
都会跟着台值期一起波动
好
然后我先稍微介绍一下
什么是套利
然后
再来就是要讲的是
大家要很了解交易的规则
或者是游戏的规则
这个也是大家很常犯的错误
就是
大家去玩那个游戏的时候
如果你是要认真玩这个游戏
你就应该非常了解这个游戏的游戏规则
无论是考试或者是交易金钱的数学游戏
你都应该非常非常了解交易规则
我常常是会拿规则来看
一条条看
或者是我遇到不确定不了解的交易规则
我就会马上打电话问我的营业员
就是
这个也是有一个好的营业员的
蛮重要
就是你的营业员如果你打给他
他会不理你
然后好几天都不回你的话
那你就应该换一个营业员
就是
重点真的不是差那个一两块的手机费
是一个能够提供你正确资讯的营业员
好
那反正就是了解交易规则很重要
然后所以你在学习一个商品的时候
你都应该很了解那个商品的游戏规则
你要先看好规则再去交易
好我稍微讲一个例子
就是
这个是在去年11月17号
礼拜三的12点51分
这个是宏达店
宏达店的现货在12点51分收86.9
就是在这个位置
这边可以看到是12点51
就是
然后收在86.9
这个是现货
然后在同一个时间它的期货12点51
收在86.1
也就是这边
所以这是同一个时间
它有0.8块钱的价差
期货跟现货
那期货跟现货
通常本质上是同一个商品
对吧
那为什么它会有0.8块的价差呢
那有人可能会猜说
因为交易成本
大台跟小台
常常会有一块钱的
一点的价差
因为一点没有办法套利
会超过交易成本
所以
可以有一点的价差
但是不会有超过三点的价差
那为什么这个价差可以到0.8
是0.89%的价差
但是交易成本
这个是交易税
然后你如果当天把它平常掉的话
当充交易税会除以2
然后这是股票的成本
然后这个是手续费
那再看你的券商如果给你三折
那你的交易成本大概是0.23%
如果是当充的话
所以交易成本还是比价差低很多
便宜很多对吧
那如果你在这时候
期货比较便宜
现货比较贵嘛
那你现在打20张
宏达电的空单
然后打10口
宏达电的多单
是不是
就是一个一定赚的套利呢
这个
大家
这个问题就是你要了解交易规则
因为当天就有人问了这个问题
蛮有趣的对吧
怎么会有这么大的价差
然后11月17号是礼拜三
这是这个故事其中一个关键
而且它是
有人大概知道
知道这个为什么会有价差吗
来 请说看看
我在想
应该有可能是
有可能是越合越结算
或是说它现货没有券
那就是可能会造成说
你现货没有办法空现货
或者说它起货当天要结算的这个原因
这样
那个
结算是对的
那天是结算
然后这是一个很重要的因素
但是不太会是现货没有券
因为现货如果没有券的话
期货就不会有人愿意卖
大家都会想买
所以其实还是不会有价差
但是
就是没有券
那个不是原因
但是是结算日
是原因
这个很重要
好
所以11月17号
礼拜三
它是结算日
那为什么结算日会有价差
这边就要讲交易规则
就是
股票
股票期货的结算价是怎么算的
有没有人知道
就是一点到一点半的那个
它的那个价格的平均
就是
对它有一个那个算法
有人要补充吗
一点到一点半的价格平均
那这是12.51
那跟后面又没差
那12.51的时候不是可以打
可以打这个单套利吗
因为不是那样子
几乎对了
但是有一些错误
有人知道吗
股票期货是怎么结算的
大家有买过股票期货吧
但大家都不知道怎么结算的
这样子好像
这样的话
就是你不了解交易规则
你就有可能会
打错误的单
对不对
股票期货它是这样
就是
我们看一下到12.58的时候
它的价差变更大
现货是在89.6
期货在87.9
刚是0.8的价差
现在是到
1.7块的价差
超巨大的价差
那因为期货
期货的结算价是
最后一个小时
60分钟
就是12.5到1.5的
每一个跳在上面的那个数字
总共661个数字的
算数平均数
就是直接加起来
除以661
这个大家知道吗
刚问好像没有人知道
就是它每几秒会跳一个价格
然后那些价钱的算数平均是结算价
所以台子期跟股票期货的结算价
都跟最后一盘的价钱
不会是同一个数字
就是加钱指数的最后一个数字
不是结算价
这个大家知道吗
很多人可能以为
最后一个数字结算价
其实你应该交易一次
有被结算过一次
你就会知道那不是结算价
是吧
那所以呢
在12.5到12.51当中
这边是在向上涨的过程吗
对不对
所以
现在12.5到12.51的
这些数字的平均
可能只有86.1
但是这边尾巴的数字到86.9了
但是因为从12.5到12.51的数字
平均还是只有86.1
所以期货的价钱在86.1
那前面那些数字的平均
其实是很容易
就是你程式抓数据
自己平均
你就可以知道
目前的平均是多少
大家听得懂
你有意思吗
听不懂的举手
很少人听不懂
你知道期货的规则吗
你没有交易过期货是吗
好吧
那你再去问营业员
你不知道什么是期货
所以
所以它在上涨的过程中
目前这些数字的平均是86.1
虽然最后一个数字是86.9
所以这个价差还很小
然后
再
但是到这个地方
89.6跟87.9
这个地方我就有介入
我就有
我就有在89.6打空单
87.9打多单
因为后面还有半个小时
它已经有1.7块的价差了
所以
只要这个价差降低了
降低到可能0.5以下的时候
我就可以两边同时平仓
我就成功套利了
对不对
那我会输的情况是什么呢
是最后
不只是最后的收盘价
跟现货
就是期货跟现货的收盘价
差1.7以上
是在接下来半个小时里面
它们的价差都没有降到0.5以下
我才会输嘛
但是
除非
它从这个地方
就一路一直喷上去
才有可能让平均
一直领先现货这么多
但是
这个情况的机会是很低的
就是如果它一直持在稍微平的地方的话
那它的平均就会被它拉上来
你们听得懂吗
那除非它一直往上
数字一直往上喷上去
那平均才会一直追不上它
但是
现在才过一半的时间
12点半到12点58
接下来半个小时它还要一直往上喷
一直往上喷
那HTC要喷回1000块吗
不太可能
就是
所以
基本上
在这个价差达到这么大程度的时候
就是
就是你去介入
实际上我在这个地方也是有去介入进场
那你就有很高的机会可以赚到钱
但这个不完全是套利
但有点接近
就是
因为你了解交易的规则
你知道自己在干嘛
那当然有一些人
他是以为
奇怪
怎么有1.7块的价差
这是不就是要送我钱
那就打印去
但是他有可能会
会没有办法正确的平常就是
因为
因为如果他
就是他最后的结算是差超过1.7
他可能没办法正确的平常
因为结算的最后一分钟
或者说四戳盘
如果喷上去了
那他可能就没有办法正确的平常
或许价差就在1.7附近
那他就没赚到
大家听得懂意思吗
不好意思
其实我是想说我问一个问题
其实我可以回去再查
但我想说
现在足笔戳合的时候
他的
他是怎么从
就是结算价格
一样是每5秒开算
因为以前
在不是足笔戳合的时候
他是5秒
现货会有5秒一次有价格
那足笔戳合的时候
我想说问一下是怎样
应该现在也还是5秒一次
对吗
是吗
应该是
是
对
还是没5秒一次
是吗
动声
对
还是没5秒一次
然后他讲的那个是一个
蛮重要的交易规则变动
就是
禁价戳合变足笔戳合
然后每一次交易规则的变动
我们都应该要
就是很了解
然后
那么
禁价戳合变成足笔戳合
让
就是
这个规则改动之后
接下来的
最近这一年
的
一年多的当成交量
这个量的数字就增加了非常的多
所以
如果你看的书是在这个规则改变之前
写的话
那他的价量关系的分析可能就会
就会不太一样
好
然后就是
大家应该能够听得懂
我看好像只有一位没有交易过
期货的同学
听不懂
其他人应该都听得懂这个故事吧
就是
你应该要了解
他的游戏规则实际上是怎样
然后你知道
这个价差
不是100%会赚的套利
但是价差大到某一个程度的时候
它是一个几乎很难赔钱的
这个价差单
大家能够听懂吧
好
能赚钱吗
很
非常的正期望值
是套利吗
就
还不到套利的程度
但非常接近
好
为什么这个价差
会持续这么久
我又打错字
我等一下要改一下
然后要非常了解游戏规则
不知道的规则
就打电话问营业员
就是我在
去年做行业五分盘的时候
我做的是比较特别的
融资融券盘内互敌的规则
然后又是储置股
然后储置股
是台湾特别制定的一些游戏规则
所以
在那一段时间我就
一直疯狂的打给营业员
而且甚至不同的券商
还有可能有不同的游戏规则
就是
有些它的信用额度
在盘中是可以
融资跟融券额度是可以
就是抵消掉的
就是你融资了
这个五百万
然后你用融券把它抵消掉五百万
你今天的额度又会归零
那有的券商是不会归零的
就甚至券商之间的游戏规则
还不一样
那这个一定要打电话
那个问你的券商问清楚
就是你要很清楚交易规则
好
就是甚至券商之间交易规则
可能不一样
然后再来就是
每次交易规则的变动都要很清楚
然后
当然你要很清楚游戏规则
然后清楚规则改了什么
然后
我刚刚说的那个当冲交易税减半
就是
好 反正就是我认为
它大概率是会一直延续下去
就是每一次快要到期的时候
政府就会说
好 我们再延期
这是我认为的想法
然后
好 我们继续讲
行为经济学的
这个是说
人不太能够正确的衡量价值
好 这是
这是
跟我们COVID-19那时候的故事有点相关
就是如果有一个
有可能会死的病
你有1/1000的机会得到
而且死掉
然后有一种疫苗
可以让你对这个病完全免疫
就是你打疫苗
你就会降低1/1000的死亡率
你最多愿意花多少钱买
就是这个疫苗卖多贵
你都还是会买
在这个
有一段时间大家抢疫苗抢得很热嘛
然后还有人特别飞去国外打疫苗
对吧
那我随便
问几个人
你
你最高愿意花多少钱
打一个
这个
让你降低1/1000的死亡率的疫苗
我还在想
那不然
如果1万块你会打吗
不会
那1000块你会打吗
考虑
考虑嘛
那就是
那5000块呢
不会
反正你就自己在那边
那2000块
好
反正就1000到5000嘛
反正就是2000到5000之间
那下一个问题是
如果现在要你进医院
第一个包裹
这个医院里面有
COVID-19的群聚感染
新闻就爆
这个医院里面的医生
好可怜
被群聚感染
然后一堆工作人员都感染
但是
必须要有人送物资进去嘛
你就要负责
推那个推车进去
然后你在外面的话
你很安全
你基本上就当作
你不会被感染COVID
但是你进去之后
你有1/1000的机会
会因此而死掉
你最少要拿到多少钱
才愿意接这个任务
好
我问同一个同学
这样才准
一万块的话
你愿意去吗
一万块
让你进医院送物资
然后你有1/1000的机会死掉
去了
去嘛
一万还是会去
还蛮酷的
那5000块呢
可能就不会了
5000块可能就不会
好
那还是有一点点差距嘛
就是
所以这个1/1000的死亡率
在这时候是
你认为价值是1万到5000
但是疫苗的时候
你觉得你1/1000的死亡率是
5000到2000嘛
但还是有差距
然后
之前我在阳明大学的通事课
的经济学
还有研究所健康经济学
都讲过几次这个课
然后
我问几次阳明大学的同学
通常男生讲的价差会比较小一点
然后女生在这个问题
很多都是说
你给我多少钱我都不去
我说那给你100万
他说不要
那有1/1000的机会会死掉
我们问一下女同学好了
你第一个打疫苗
你最高愿意花多少钱打
一万块
最高愿意花一万
那如果要第一个包裹
你最少要拿多少钱
可能不会冒险
不会冒险
如果100万呢
100万可以
100万会
好吧
那反正
不是不会冒险吗
但是
我坚决否认
我坚决不同意
但100万可以
是这样的意思吗
本来要大声自责
但钱实在太多了
好
那就是
就是反正
这个让我们知道
人其实不知道怎么衡量价值
就是
都是1/1000的死亡率
但是
就是
我们其实不知道
自己1/1000的死亡率
价值多少
那其实
不只是这个点
就是因为传统经济学认为
我们决定要不要买一个东西
是
会衡量这个东西的价值
跟这个价钱
哪一个高哪一个低
但其实每一个东西的价值
都是一直在那边浮动
会受到非常多因素
而影响你的判断
因为我们就是真的不知道
每个东西多少钱
那当然股票也是这样
好
然后
这个
这个是我
就是在去年7月的时候
这个
就是回去稍微暂时当一下医生
就是那时候
好像很缺医生
然后我觉得
台湾因为我少了一个医生
觉得心里有点过意不去
就稍微去
去
去帮忙一下
那个柯文哲那时候
就
就拍那个
影片说
这个
希望退休的医护人员
回来支援
当然他口词没那么清晰
他可能说
这个
这个医疗支援的问题
我觉得很刺脖
这个
很难搞
就是
退休的医护人员大概是这样讲
但反正大概是那个意思
好
反正
那时候我就回去
然后
当时
每一天
就是
直接接触
COVID-19这些病人
可以得到的钱
是
1万块
然后甚至
就
就已经有人
为了
接触一次
可以得到1万块的钱
会跟别人吵架
就是
因为大家都想要
这个
一次接触
就是
拿1万块
因为1万块
就是还是蛮多
就是还是蛮多的
好
但我
就我说的是
那个
好
反正就是有人这样子
然后
但是那时候打疫苗
就是
曾经有人特别出国
好
反正就是这样
就是人不知道怎么
知道价值
然后那时候稍微去做一下善事
然后这个是
我在
这个
去支援COVID-19病房的
这个我有PO在Facebook
就是
有一天
我穿全套房屋去处理COVID-19
但是我又觉得
那天
在早盘的
这个
就是他的
数据就显示
那天很有可能
长荣会大跌
所以我在
这个
进
病房之前
我就
打了5张长荣的空单
然后出来的时候
就是
过一个小时
已经停利
赚了7万块
然后
这是另外一个
我的医生朋友
他就说
我连在COVID-19病房
裁剪都可以当冲
就是
这个就是
那个
就是
让电脑自己
帮你交易的好处
就是连我在
穿着房布衣
在那边做事的时候
就是
反正我的策略
有在电脑上执行
那我就有可能
一个小时
就已经赚7万块
好
反正这个
这个是在FB上也有的
所以这就是
自动停损停利单的好处
就是
他出价到
停损或停利的点位
他就会自己
帮你把那个单
给出价打出去
那哪一家券商
有这个
自动停损停利功能呢?
这个
好像不太能讲
反正
大概就是这样子
这个是真的
真的很好用
然后
就是
倒价停损
打到那个价前
就要把它出出去
应该有很多人有经历过
你设那个地方是停损点
然后
它在那个停损点上下附近震荡
然后你一直不知道
到底
这样子是不是会害自己被洗出去
然后就不停损
但是其实有这个线形是
如果这个线形是
这样子下来
然后在这边震荡的话
那很有可能是一个
非常快速的往下掉下去的
的线形
因为
因为如果线形是这样
然后在这边震的话
那可能有些人跟你停损
一样摔在这边
或者是
就是
如果这样到这边的话
只要往下一点点
就会有很多人跟你一起引发停损
然后他往下一点
他就整个喷下去
这个线形大家也可以稍微知道一下
那
就是因为你知道会有很多人
他下来
然后在这边震荡的话
再下去就会一起停损
反正就是
就是
前不久加运货币也有
类似这样的线形
然后
好
看一下现在的时间
那我最后的这些是
一些常见
其他常见的人性偏物
第一个就是
这个大家可能不太知道
怎么控制时间
好
所以我做的方式是
我后面放了一大堆的故事
然后我每个都只有标题
这样我没讲你们也不知道
好
然后再来是这个自治力
就是
反正因为这是一个
这个
在杨文明大学可以讲很久的课
所以反正后面有很多可以讲
缺乏自治力是这样
就是
在传统的经济学的想法里面
你把
在减肥的时候
你把饼干
还有那些零食放在桌上
是没有坏处的
因为你有更多的选择
如果你真的非常需要马上吃的时候
你就会去吃那些零食
那不然在其他的时候
如果吃零食是比其他更不好的选择
那你就不会吃零食
但显然你把零食收在很远的柜子里
跟放在桌上比起来
就是
你放在桌上会比较有可能吃它
对吧
那这个其实就是
因为我刚刚说的
我们做的决定只跟
过去思考的习惯
和当下的刺激有关
你当下不太有这个刺激
你就比较不会做那个决定
然后你一直给自己这个刺激
你就有机率会做这个决定
大家听得懂吗
就是传统经济学认为
把零食放在桌上是没差的
只有好处没有坏处
但其实它很有坏处
好
那这个缺乏自制力
也是常见的人性谬误
增加自制力意志力的方法
就是减少选择跟自我绑架
一个是
就是
增加你自己
就是做不好的事情的成本
然后还有提高你做好的事情
可以得到的好处
那减少选择
就例如说
有些人说什么
读书的时候
就把手机直接关机
然后可能放到很高的衣柜里
然后你就不太能滑手机
你就会看书
或是把临时收起来
然后自我绑架
自我绑架就是例如说
你就到K书中心
然后那边超安静的
然后如果你只要发出一点声音
就有一个人说
不要超
那这样的话你可能就会
比较自我绑架一点
然后另外一个自我绑架的方式
这个也是我在之前高校学习的方法
那堂课里面有讲过的
就是你把你要做的事情
PO在你的社交软件上
Facebook IG或FB
让很多你在意的朋友都会看到
像我今年就有PO
我今年的三个目标
就是从82.6%减到70公斤
然后YouTube从7000个订阅到3万个订阅
然后最后一个是
今年投资报酬率60%
然后我现在已经从72.6%
82.6%一个月减到76公斤
目前一个月已经扣6.6公斤
然后另外一个就是
我跟我朋友打赌嘛
看谁减肥减得比较快
一个月就输五千这样
这也是一个好的方法
好反正就是
在传统经济学里面
就是这些都是无关因素嘛
你PO一个文
怎么会让你比较容易减肥成功呢
但实际上就是会嘛
好这个是减少选择跟自我绑架
那就是例如说你连续输两单
你就不要再下单了
那你就直接把下单软体关掉
然后你去做一件固定的事
例如说你就去看书
或是你就带你的狗去跑步
因为我有养狗
所以我可能会带我的狗去跑步
那如果你的不下单的方法是
坐在盘前
然后开着那个闪电下单
然后在那边看
算了我今天不下单了
但我想知道接下来的剧情
因为那个其实对我来说就是剧情嘛
可恶到底会不会回档
哇塞怎么回档了
这个啊刚损错了
我刚看法是对的
来再打这单再打回去
那就不行嘛
这个就不是减少选择自我绑架的方法
那你应该想办法让自己就是尽量做到
好所以这个给大家一个建议的回家功课
就是回去在你的社交软件上
把你今年的三个目标PO出来
然后这三个目标呢
要明确要有量化的数字
就是你要写的是像我的那三个
这样有数字不要是什么
减肥然后认真学习
然后尽量加油
就不要什么读书这样
读书就是写读几本书
减肥就写减到几公斤
好不好
好这个大家可以回去PO自己今年的三个目标
好然后
这个是自我绑架嘛
使用出价单让交易机械花
好
然后这个下一个故事是
最小可便差
好就是
两种情况
第一个情况呢
是你现在要买一支铅笔
然后这支铅笔呢
如果你去一个小时车程外的一家商场
大卖场买的话
这支铅笔是10块
但是楼下也有一个人他是卖铅笔的
他一支铅笔卖210块
那你会不会愿意花一个小时
坐车去大卖场买10块的铅笔
还是你会去跟楼下那个人买210元的同样一支铅笔
会坐车去买一个小时外的铅笔
好像其实很少耶
那会去楼下跟他买210块的铅笔的铅笔
其他人就不买了是不是
你需要那个铅笔啊
好 有点少人举手
还是两个都很不爽
所以妈 我就不买了
妈 一个那么远 一个那么贵
气死我了 是吗
不是 你就要买那铅笔
你可能住在美国啊
你可能
因为台湾很方便嘛
美国很多地方
你随便去一个地方
开支都要开一个小时耶
好 可能台湾比较没这个问题啦
所以大家
那
其实很多人会愿意去很远的卖场买铅笔
因为楼下210块一支铅笔
他是卖爱心笔是不是
是不是你一下楼他就说
这支笔拿啦拿啦拿啦
我是设计系的学生支持一下
这太扯了吧
一支笔210块
很多人会愿意去很远的卖场买
那如果现在你要买的
是一台电脑
然后你在楼下买是50200
但是去一个小时外的卖场是5万块
你是不是有可能就会在楼下买
而且很有可能
比刚刚那个例子的机率大非常多
就是你开一个小时也才省200块
那哪有差
就这个5万块的东西差200块有差吗
这个就是最小可变差
在这两个故事里面
我们衡量的是同一件事情
我们要不要花一个小时的车程去省200块
但你在两个事情里面
大家会勾第一个学校和第二个学校的比例
有非常大的落差
这个是经济学家的实验
这就是最小可变差
就是我们其实不一定是去衡量这个时间
有没有获得这一个好处
例如说那个什么星巴尔科买一送一
直接就我直接排爆欸
那个
就能处理一下
这就是最小时的认识
这个是一个小时的认识
那是一种认识
这个是一种认识
的一种认识
就是一种认识
认为大家是用某一个方式
考虑
但是太扯了
大家又不是经济学家
大家就不是用那个方式考虑的
我看一下
还有好多个故事可以讲
我尽量都讲短一点
让大家每个都乒乓一下
大概知道有这些故事
这样就好了
好
丙複交应就是
人会过度珍视自己拥有的物品
会太过高估自己拥有
那个东西的价值
那这个在股票上也有可能
就是你已经有那个股票之后
你就觉得那个股票价值应该更高
那所以我才会买嘛
那总不会我是错的吧
对吧
因为大家会比较不想相信自己是错的
然后就是
例如说
也是一个舞会的门票
然后就是
有些人已经有抽奖抽到那个门票了
然后
在那个学校里面
有些人可以
花钱
去跟那些人买门票
然后你问那些要买门票的人
这张门票
你愿意花多少钱
大部分人可能说三百五百
但是说那卖那个门票的人
你最低愿意用多少卖
他可能会说七百一千
就是他会觉得因为我自己有这个门票
而过度高估了这个门票拥有的价值
那就是
我突然想到
大家挂单
停例是那个数字
你就挂那个数字
你不要每次都喜欢
故意多挂个三块五块
就是
三点五点
那就不是你的策略嘛
就是你想说
那这样我每次不都多赚三点五点
但是你回测的时候
你用什么样的数据回测
你就用什么样的方式去下单
你就是设三R
那你为什么一定要挂单
都挂三点一R呢
那是不是在你回测的数据里面
那个三跟三点一之间的数据
就跟实际情况不一样了
好我只是突然想到这件事情
然后心理账户
就是
拿麦克风手好酸
欢迎一只手拿
心理账户就是
我们会把
一样是一千块
然后但是我们认为
它是不同的一千块
就是
这个一千块
都是钱
但是如果我
这个礼拜
已经跟朋友出去唱了两字的歌
花了一千块了
那有可能会因此而减损
我今天花五百块去看电影的意愿
但其实你
你这礼拜已经花一千块唱两次歌
跟你今天要不要去花五百块看电影
是无关的
但是我会在心里觉得
我这个月
关于娱乐的支出
已经在这个类别里面被花光了
就是我心里会偷偷弄一些预算
然后这个预算已经花光了
反正我把这个故事讲成很简短的版本
大家应该听得懂的意思吧
就是我们会
行为经济学里面有一个
很常说的话就是
无关因素都很有关
这些在传统经济学里面
都叫做无关因素的因素
其实才是我们
人性真的会拿来做决定考虑的点
然后心里账户
任劣损失
就是
这故事讲就是
如果现在
这个
申讯又要去听
这个周杰伦的演唱会
然后但是那一天
却台风
但又没达到放假的标准
反正他就是继续唱
那个小绿蛋租了
也没那么好退嘛
能不取消就不取消
可是风雨很大
出门有点危险
然后他又驻外县市
可能要从基隆
过去很远
然后可能有点危险
如果这个一万块
的演唱会门票
他是花一万块买的
拼死拼活都要去小巨蛋
就我被风吹走都没关系
我都花一万块
但是你问他说
如果这个门票
是你抽奖抽到的免费票呢
他就觉得
好像也没关系
那不去就算了
好这个是台风跟演唱会的故事
然后
另一个
心理账户
就是
健身房
健身房在
这个
他通常会
让你一次缴一年的年费
然后
你会在前几个月去
然后后面你就
会慢慢就不去了
因为你在前几个月的时候
你可以感受到
你缴的那个会费
但是后来你就
就感受不到
然后
短视经营是人
会过度错估未来的价值
就是
就是人会
通常是低估未来的价值
但有时候也是高估
像选择权的
卖方
就是因为选择权的价值
卖方的价钱
通常都是一直被高估一点点的
好
好像时间差不多了
然后选美比赛跟股市分析是说
就是
选美比赛是大家要
在一个杂志上面
比赛就是
你能不能够在这
100个美女里面
选到最多人
选的那个美女
的号码
那
你应该要怎么选呢
你要选你觉得
最正的那个女生
还是你要选你觉得
别人觉得最正的那个女生
显然是第二个对吧
大家听得懂吧
你要选到
大家都会打多单的那个股票
打多单
还是你要选你自己觉得
基本面最好
但别人不觉得的公司
应该是
大家觉得很好
会打多单的公司
对吧
这就是卖方便比赛
跟股市分析
应该有一些人是
这个交易生
Aster大的粉丝
应该有吧
这个他的演讲
通常也都会
让大家玩一个游戏
就是每个人讲一个
一到一百的数字
然后比赛
猜
谁跟
那个
数字的平均的三分之二
最接近
这个也是
你要去猜别人
会猜什么数字
而不是
就是
就是你应该是要去
预测市场不理性的程度
然后我最后这个讲很快
因为最后这集的故事就
没那么多时间讲
因为它是一堂很长的课
所以我今天浓缩到三个小时讲
然后尽量讲一些跟交易有关的事情来当例子
然后今天主要take-on-messie就是
人不是理性的
市场是错的
而且人的不理性方向可以被预测
预测的方式就是行为经济学
好
那今天就讲到这边
谢谢大家